sa vie si dans l'année ça bouge pas
après faudra passer la vitesse
supérieure pour sensibiliser aux gens ce
sera une grève de la faim je ne sais pas
ce qui m'est c'est vrai que si ça prend
quand un an deux ans ça c'est
désespérant
[Musique]
non
on nous on est déjà passé par exemple à
côté de plusieurs médicaments qui
étaient assez efficace et lui il ya un
risque qu'on passe à côté nous aussi en
fait juste pour des histoires de
bureaucratie c'est à dire il faut
d'abord qu'ils aient une validation par
le m
et ça ça a pris plus de six mois huit
mois ça a pris huit mois en france il
fallait avoir ce qu'on appelle une hâte
et une autre reste en place a en gros si
vous étiez mourant moins de 40 % de
capacité pulmonaire en attente de greffe
balla le laboratoire et la france
faisait un effort pour vous le donner en
fait
[Musique]
et en fait une zone où il a il est à peu
près deux heures de soins par jour
il a il a décliné qui viennent tous les
jours en fait pour ventiler les poumons
le sport est important aussi et après il
a des aérosols en fait ben la manière à
les hydrater et nettoyer le poumon il a
pas mal de médicaments aussi tout ce qui
est dj stiff
[Musique]
on a fait j'ai fait énormément de temmar
chez moi avec ma femme fait on a
l'impression qu'on se bat contre du vent
en fait j'ai écrit au président de la
république à la première dame
j'ai écrit également à l'achat
s et j'ai reçu une réponse que de la has
actuellement en me disant que oui il
était sensible à j'ai été sensible à
notre à nos préoccupations mais en gros
ils n'ont pas répondu plus que ça c'est
un parcours du groupe combattant
incroyable
[Musique]